have you seen this map of all the coups
happening in Africa lately a coup is
where someone usually the military
illegally overthrows the government and
just takes over and here in central
Africa there have been 11 coup attempts
since 2020. almost all of them have been
successful including this one that just
happened in Gabon the UN Secretary
General is calling this an epidemic of
coups and that's because when one
military successfully overthrows their
government and the International
Community doesn't really do anything
there's sort of a contagious effect
where would be coup plotters in nearby
countries feel emboldened to do the same
thing the reason why all of this is
happening now is because of a real
contagion called covid-19 which really
ruptured these fragile economies leading
to higher prices dissatisfied people and
creating the perfect conditions for the
military to come in and overthrow the
government all of this marks a sharp
decline for democracy in this region if
you want to better understand
International politics follow for more